HERE AND POLICE AT THE READY TO
FINISH A JOB READY TO HOLD THE
LINE FOR AS LONG AS WE NEED TO.
>> Tucker: MIKE TOBIN LIVE IN
WASHINGTON, THANKS SO MUCH.
WE ARE STILL WAITING TO HEAR IF
THE LEADER OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATE MITCH McCONNELL IS
CLOSE TO GETTING TO THE FLOOR
AND OF COURSE WE WILL HAVE MORE
IN WHAT IS HAPPENING, BOMBARDED
WITH IMAGES WHAT TOOK PLACE IN
WASHINGTON, TOO LITTLE HAS BEEN
SPENT ON WHY.
ANYONE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
SIGNIFICANCE OUGHT TO WATCH THE
VIDEO OF THE WOMAN WHO WAS SHOT
INSIDE THE U.S. CAPITOL THIS
AFTERNOON.
IN THE FOOTAGE WHICH YOU CAN
FIND ON THE INTERNET, THE WOMAN
IS STANDING IN A HALLWAY OFF THE
HOUSE FLOOR.
SHE APPEARS TO BE IN HER 20s,
SHE’S GOT AN AMERICAN FLAG TIED
AROUND HER NECK, THE SCENE
AROUND HER IS CHAOTIC, PEOPLE
ARE BUMPING INTO EACH OTHER,
TRYING TO GET INTO THE SENATE
CHAMBER.
WITH NO WARNING THERE IS
GUNFIRE, YOU HEAR A SHOT AND THE
WOMAN FALLS.
SHE’S BEEN HIT WITH A BULLET, IT
SEEMS LIKE THE NECK, COULD BE
THE CHEST, APPARENTLY WAS FIRED
BY SOMEONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IF PEOPLE IN THE HALLWAY
SCREAMED.
THE CAMERA CLOSES IN ON THE
WOMAN’S FACE, SHE LOOKS STUNNED.
SHE IS STARING STRAIGHT AHEAD
UNBLINKING.
IN HER EYES YOU CAN SEE SHE
KNOWS SHE IS ABOUT TO DIE WHICH
IN THE END SHE DID.
SHE DIED A COUPLE HOURS AGO AT A
LOCAL HOSPITAL.
WHAT CAN WE LEARN FROM THIS,
IT’S NOT ENOUGH TO CALL IT A
TRAGEDY.
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND GETTING A
CALL AND LEARNING THAT WAS YOUR
DAUGHTER.
THE LAST TIME SHE SPOKE TO HER
SHE WAS HEADING TO WASHINGTON
FOR A POLITICAL RALLY, NOW SHE’S
DEAD.
PHIL NEVER TALKED TO HER AGAIN,
IMAGINE THAT.
IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN IT WILL PUT
YOU IN THE RIGHT FRAME OF MIND.
WE WILL BE WATCHING A LOT MORE
OF IT IN THE COMING DAYS,
POLITICAL VIOLENCE BEGETS
POLITICAL VIOLENCE, THAT IS
ALWAYS TRUE, IT IS AN IRON LAW
AND NEVER CHANGES, WE HAVE TO BE
AGAINST THAT NO MATTER WHO
COMMITS THE VIOLENCE OR UNDER
WHAT PRETEXT.
NO MATTER HOW MANY SELF
INTERESTED DEMAGOGUES ASSURE US
VIOLENCE IS JUSTIFIED AS THEY
HAVE BEEN ASSURING US, LYING TO
US FOR THE PAST SIX MONTHS.
WE HAVE A DUTY TO OPPOSE ALL OF
THIS, NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE
POLITICAL VIOLENCE KILLS OTHER
PEOPLE’S CHILDREN WHICH IT DOES,
BUT IN THE END IT DOESN’T WORK.
NO GOOD PERSON WILL LIVE A
HAPPIER LIFE BECAUSE THAT GIRL
WAS KILLED IN THE HALLWAY OF THE
CAPITAL TODAY.
OUR ONLY OPTION AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER IS TO FIX WHAT IS CAUSING
THIS IN THE FIRST PLACE, WE
DON’T HAVE A CHOICE.
YOU MAY HAVE NOTHING IN COMMON
WITH THE PEOPLE ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE COUNTRY, INCREASING
WE PROBABLY DON’T BUT YOU’RE
STUCK WITH THEM.
THE IDEA THAT GROUPS OF
AMERICANS WILL BREAK OFF INTO
SEPARATE, PEACEFUL NATIONS OF
LIKE-MINDED CITIZENS, THAT’S A
FANTASY, THAT WILL NOT HAPPEN.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
PEACEFUL SEPARATION, THERE NEVER
HAS BEEN AND THERE WON’T BE.
THE TWO HEMISPHERES OF THIS
COUNTRY ARE SEPARATELY
INTERTWINED, COJOINED THE TWINS.
NEITHER CAN LEAVE WITHOUT
KILLING THE OTHER.
THAT’S THE FIRST THING TO KNOW.
AS HORRIFYING AS THIS MOMENT IS,
WE HAVE NO OPTION BUT TO MAKE IT
BETTER, GOT IT OUT.
THE SECOND THING TO CONSIDER AND
IT’S RELATED TO THE FIRST IS WHY
THE WOMAN WHO WAS KILLED TODAY
WENT TO THE RALLY IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
WE DON’T KNOW ABOUT HER BUT SHE
DIDN’T LOOK RADICAL, SHE BORE NO
RESEMBLANCE TO THE ANGRY
CHILDREN WE’VE SEEN AGAIN AND
AGAIN WRECKING OUR CITIES,
SETTING FIRE AND SCRAPING
SLOGANS ON STATUES, SHE DIDN’T
LOOK LIKE THAT.
THE WOMAN IN THE CAPITAL HALLWAY
LOOKED LIKE EVERYONE ELSE, SO
WHY WAS SHE THERE ON A
WEDNESDAY?
WHY WERE ANY OF THEM THERE
TODAY?
WE OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU WANT TO FIX IT, YOU HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
THE ONLY REASON THIS COUNTRY IS
RICH AND SUCCESSFUL IS FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS WE’VE ENJOYED
A STABLE POLITICAL SYSTEM AND
THE ONLY REASON THAT SYSTEM IS
STABLE IS BECAUSE IT’S A
DEMOCRACY, DEMOCRACY IS OUR
PRESSURE RELEASE VALVE, AS LONG
AS PEOPLE SINCERELY BELIEVE SHE
CAN CHANGE THINGS BY VOTING,
THEY STAY CALM, THEY DON’T STORM
THE BASTILLE, THEY DON’T BURST
INTO THE HOUSE CHAMBER, THEY
TALK AND THEY ORGANIZE AND THEY
VOTE.
THE OPPOSITE IS ALSO TRUE, IF
PEOPLE BEGIN TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE DEMOCRACY IS FRAUDULENT,
IF THEY CONCLUDED THAT VOTING IS
A CHARADE, THE SYSTEM IS RIGGED
AND IT’S RUN IN SECRET BY A
SMALL GROUP OF POWERFUL
DISHONEST PEOPLE, THEN GOD KNOWS
WHAT COULD HAPPEN.
ACTUALLY WE DO KNOW WHAT COULD
HAPPEN, IT’S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
NOW.
IT’S HAPPENING IN COUNTLESS
OTHER COUNTRIES OVER CENTURIES
AND THE CYCLE IS THE SAME
BECAUSE HUMAN NATURE DOESN’T
CHANGE.
LISTEN TO US, SHUT UP AND DO
WHAT YOU’RE TOLD REPLY THE
LEADERS.
THE FIRST INSTINCT OF
ILLEGITIMATE LEADERSHIP IS TO
CRACK DOWN ON THE POPULATION.
CRACKDOWNS NEVER MAKE IT BETTER.
INSTEAD THEY ALWAYS MAKE THE
COUNTRY MORE VOLATILE AND MORE
DANGEROUS, THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
DON’T CARE TO LEARN OR LISTEN
BECAUSE ALL OF THIS CONVERSATION
IS A REFERENDUM ON THEM AND
THEIR LEADERSHIP SO THEY CLAMP
DOWN HARDER.
OBEY, I TELL YOU, OBEY!
IT ENDS BADLY EVERY SINGLE TIME.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN THEY WON’T TRY
IT AGAIN, OF COURSE THEY WILL
BECAUSE IT’S THEIR NATURE, IT’S
HOW WE GOT HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN SINCERELY
BELIEVE THE LAST ELECTION WAS
FAKE.
YOU CAN DISMISS THEM AS CRAZY,
CALL THEM CONSPIRACY THEORISTS,
KICK THEM OFF TWITTER, THAT
WON’T CHANGE THEIR MINDS.
RATHER THAN TRY TO CHANGE THEIR
MINDS TO CONVINCE THEM AND
REASSURE THEM THE SYSTEM IS REAL
DEMOCRACY WORKS AS HE WOULD DO
IF YOU CARED ABOUT THE COUNTRY,
OUR NEW LEADERS WILL TRY TO
SILENCE THEM.
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY WILL BE USED
BY PEOPLE TAKING POWER TO
JUSTIFY STRIPPING YOU WITH THE
RIGHTS WERE BORN WITH AS
UN-AMERICAN.
YOUR RIGHT TO SPEAK WITHOUT
BEING CENSORED, YOUR RIGHT TO
ASSEMBLE, TO NOT BE SPIED UPON,
TO MAKE A LIVING, TO DEFEND YOUR
FAMILY MOST CRITICALLY.
THESE ARE THE MOST BASIC AND
ANCIENT FREEDOMS WE HAVE, THEY
ARE WHY WE LIVE HERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE, WHY WE ARE PROUD TO
BE AMERICANS, THEY ARE WHAT MAKE
US DIFFERENT AND THEY ARE ALL
NOW IN PERIL.
WHEN THOUSANDS OF YOUR
COUNTRYMEN STORM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING, YOU DON’T HAVE TO LIKE
IT, WE DON’T.
YOU CAN BE HORRIFIED BY THE
VIOLENCE AND AS WE SAID AND WE
WILL SAY IT AGAIN, WE ARE
HORRIFIED.